so at the moment we've been working with
the inverse trig functions and just
yesterday we developed the derivatives
for these guys remember that so where
we're going to begin this time now that
we've got it up their sleeves we are
going to go back to our normal order for
things and do so quiet and tan do the
derivative of sine of us we had to do
some fancy stuff with low E if you've
got a function what the druid in on its
inverse is so that dy DX DX or dy is
this okay we also have to know the
Pythagorean identity and we had to be
careful with this to remember this we
use this fact to use this back but we
have to be careful with it because that
equation i just wrote on the wall board
is not always true only true sometimes
what was the domain we were interested
in for this particular one river from
from negative pi/2 to pi/2 cos x is
positive that part of wrath right this
is the part of the graph that are we
referring to okay so look it's all above
the access to it except for these bits
so that's why we can say this by the way
there's a great little arm there's a
great little paradise you can trick
people with if you sort of look at this
you can sort of do that with the
Pythagorean identity just without
knowing much about it and then if you
put in a value outside that domain you
can very easily show like 0 negative 1
on one of the say how did that work
right so little easy ways to treat
people when they forget hey domain
really matters okay it's a really easy
place for essential one students to show
they understand things better then into
unit where domain restrictions never
come up as nearly as frequently as an
extension one okay so that's what we did
what was the derivative we got out the
other one developed one on square root
of 16 bit bigger now before we move off
this guy I didn't make [ __ ]
the projectors on the trolley okay um I
did mention to you that these results
these industry derivatives and so on
they're on your reference sheet however
this what I just wrote is not in the
reference sheet so something else has
written there and we're going to get to
them okay so firstly when you love a
look at this one of the easiest
extension services or chamber okay what
happens when you say not the derivative
of this guy but the derivative of any
kind of function in here okay so an easy
example of what you might put it there
is this okay this is like a very very
simple example what we were doing I am
treatable for just polynomials raised to
a car putting ax plus B in there was a
very common sort of thing what happens
when we do this let's just look at this
is a simple case i'm going to drew on
the inside then i'm going to do the on
the outside ok so in this case good one
it's an easy dear adopted son right what
is it it's just a right so instead of a
one being on the top I would like it Amy
all the time when you go to them to go
over there done you've got to be careful
a very easy thing to forget ins ah it's
it's the square fighters as square as
always that but I don't have an X here
right so this thing here is ax or
squared that whole function is being
squared whatever is in there is being
squared so I really will have one
takeaway and squared X wet underneath
the square root now this is true just
not very deep or elegant it's not it's
certainly not more not more useful than
the previews designed it's very easy to
get out there it's not as a result that
comes up that appears on your reference
sheet with a bit of modification this is
the one that you go can you see where
you got this a at the top of you it
never interacts with this nothing
happens to sort of put them together
there's nothing like that's as simple as
it gets to be great however if you were
to say instead of x this constant
if that's a coefficient if you were to
divide something a little more
interesting happens okay so let's work
through this again the divot inside and
then on the outside during the inside
function this case is what I am so that
goes off on the numeral let me have a
look at your denominator again it's the
square root of one take away this whole
thing guess where yeah so that's x
squared divided by a squared come in
bloody fix it so you can see here I can
do something further here and it will be
sort of issues right is this over here
this one on a is really an a on the
denominator do agree with that like
having a fraction of the numerator is
really multiply or divide but this a
outside of the square root I can bring
it inside the square root do you see
that when the a bruise from the outside
to the inside it becomes an a squared so
if i restore that one on the top and i
multiply through everything underneath
the square by a square then you get this
that's kind of nice that's kind of neat
and and concise it's almost as elegant
as this you can kind of see this is the
special case where a is equal to one do
you see that 181 a squared they're the
same thing okay so this just out here is
almost one that you see on your
reference sheet okay with one difference
most of the things that will most of the
characters results you see in your
reference sheet and on actually in this
differentiate it gives you that but they
give it to you the other way around
because we know every statement a data
derivative if you look at it from the
other direction is this statement about
integration right so that's why my
heading here was calculus with inverse
trig functions because it's not just
differentiation we working with now
we're always thinking about and there's
something our differentiation I also
know sign
education ok so right along psyche out
what integration say but what I think
out of this line I can't just write it
straight away what would I what I right
here to go off yeah this going to
preview and I've integrating with
respect to X DX equals what inverse sine
Samuel s plus pi closet very good okay
now this is what you see this is the
result bits of the reference me however
before we go any further I just point
something interesting here right you
notice so diverse x ave oakland and
there's a constant of integration so
that means i can move this thing up and
down okay one of the curious these this
is why i am i'm gonna need some cables
actually could someone give me here it's
a black cable down there and i want to
show you the reference sheet you for a
second thank you tie one of the things
that interesting is we can go through
this same process and in fact as i'm
doing this I'd like you lee i would like
me to go through the same process we can
do this through this exact same process
to develop a statement just like this
for tan inverse do you agree it ends up
looking a little bit different started
off it only takes a few lines you know
the derivative is try this case again
what happens when you divide through by
a again something sought a nice indeed
happens a little bit different give it a
shot when you do that good morning it's
not complicated the matter of it is not
complicated but then it seems like
something's missing on the reference
sheet so i want you to have you got the
turning this one and then i will show
you what is missing